Hank: Good morning John, it's Friday.
John: In fact it is Black Friday, the day
--
Hank: The darkest Friday of the year, the
blackest, deepest, dark.
It's so ominous.
John: Everything is 20% off at dftba.com through
Monday, I think that is great news.
Hank: It's bad for us.
John: It's kinda bad for us.
Hank: We're crazy!
John: Have you ever seen, uh, an advertisement
for "Don's Guns" in Indianapolis?
Hank: No, I don't live in Indianapolis.
John: He sells guns, and at the end of every
commercial, he says, "I don't want to make
any money, I just love to sell guns."
Hank: *laughs* It's basically --
John: That's how I feel about hoodies.
Hank: I'm glad you don't feel that way about
guns.
John: Let's start the video over.
Hank: I think that was all gold.
John: Okay!
Hank: Black Friday is the day that happens
after Thanksgiving.
John: Thanksgiving is the day where we say
what we are thankful for.
So we thought that today we would say some
of the things that we are thankful for.
Hank: Yeah!
John: I am thankful that childhood death around
the world is decreasing at an astonishing
pace, uh, that we are maybe only 30 or 40
years away from the vast majority of poor
countries being middle income countries.
Hank: That is a different direction than I
was going to go for the video.
I was thinking more like, "I'm thankful that
farts sound funny because otherwise they would
just be farts and it would just be stinky,
but with the funny sound, they're awesome.
John: I am also really grateful for Nerdfighteria,
uh, for like the chance to be part of a community
that's committed to doing good and also having
a lot of fun.
Hank: I'm thankful for, like, human hair.
Because I think it's like, I think it's pretty,
and functional.
Hank: I'm thankful for people who work in
customer support.
John: Uh, I'm so thankful for everyone who
works in retail today, I have worked a Black
Friday or two in my life and it is not easy.
John: I'm really grateful that there's this
young generation of people who are committed
activists and working hard to decrease Worldsuck
on lots of fronts in their communities.
I think that's really exciting -
Hank: I'm grateful for all the things that
you were grateful for.
I'm also grateful that my dog is cool with
uh, me being the person who decides when and
where she poops.
Like, I would not put up with that.
John: You know what else I'm grateful for?
I'm grateful uh, that when I show up in Missoula,
Montana with no winter clothes because I've
been, uh, in North Carolina, that, uh, I happen
to own part of a warehouse that sells hoodies.
I can just layer myself in infinite hoodies.
Hank: Yeah, you could -- Right, you could
go from small all the way to extra extra large
and you could --
John: Realistically, I could go from large
all the way to extra extra large.
Hank: *laughs*
Hank: Here's one - Here's a serious one, here's
a serious one.
I am thankful that the earth's core is partially
liquid, allowing for currents in conductive
materials that produce the earth's electromagnetic
field, which allows us to go outside in the
daytime and not die.
John: Is that really true?
Hank: Yeah -
John: I'm thankful for that -
Hank: *laughs*
John: That sounds like a huge win!
Hank: Yeah!
John: I'm also grateful that humans landed
a thing on a comet.
Hank: This is so much harder than it sounds.
John: It sounds incredibly hard!
There's a comet, it's like 'vrrrr, vrrr vrrrr'
and we're like "I know what we'll do.
We'll shoot a slingshot and it'll hit the
comet."
You know what that reminds me of?
The miracle of AFC Wimbledon's journey to
League Two!
I gave one of these to Henry and you know
what he said when I put it on him?
Hank: What?
John: He said, "I'm gonna grow into this."
Hank: *Laughs*
Hank: There's a lot of things to be thankful
for!
John: I wanna know what you're thankful for,
Nerdfighteria!
Hank: Yeah!
I wanna know a serious thing you're thankful
for and a silly thing you're thankful for.
John: I have to go and sign posters now.
I don't have the normal-est brain, and nothing
makes my brain feel calmer and happier than
signing over and over and over again.
It brings me great joy.
Nerdfighters, thank you for allowing me to
sign so many things in the last year.
I hope to be able to keep it up for the rest
of my life.
Hank: That is weird.
John, I will see you on Friday.
John: It will be Tuesday, and also right now.
Hank: No Friday, today is Friday.
John: Oh!
Perfect.
Good ending.
John: Everything, everything here, everything
at dftba.com is 20% off now through Monday,
including signed posters, the hoodie that
I'm wearing, AFC Wimbledon scarves, everything
at dftba.com, we've got lots of amazing stuff,
it's all 20% off, so head over to dftba.com
link in the dooblydoo or click on my face.